[Musique]
ma vie n'a pas été celle que vous devez
vous imaginez nos traversant tous des
épreuves
vous êtes déjà tombée amoureuse il y à
très très longtemps
et vous je ne sais combien de fois tout
le temps
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le futur
la vie est belle mais elle peut l'être
encore plus
pourquoi ne s'est-elle pas il suffit de
le vouloir
imaginez que tous vos désirs soit enfin
exaucé je vais sauver des gens mais toi
tu souffre le monde
steve diana
bien sûr
on échange je prends ce que je veux
en taule montayral
[Musique]
le monde a besoin de toi
ce qu'il te reste à faire
[Musique]
rien de bon au nez des mensonges
et la grandeur n'est pas ce que vous
croyez
tout ça c'est de l'art
ça c'est une poubelle ça c'est une
poubelle
eh oui
[Musique]